okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p what
are we talking about today it's been a
weird weird day here we got a voicemail
and that voicemail is about jordan
Peterson and it's been a while I know
the audience there's a contingent of the
audience that loves Jordan Peters and
stuff and then there's the bulk of the
audience which despises Jordan Peters
and stuff they just don't care about him
they don't care about what he says they
don't care about what the audience says
about what he says it's been weeks and
weeks and I did get a question about
Jordan Peterson take a listen hey David
why does it seem like now that there's
so many young men that seem to be lost
and society now and don't seem to know
what to do or what their place is in
this world
right and why is it that they all seem
to be gravitating towards Jordan
Peterson is there
I guess Messiah or leader or person to
look up to yeah what is it about now
that makes this a huge thing yep very
good question here's what's going on
feeling lost in the world an existential
crisis a midlife crisis a quarter life
crisis whatever right these are not
uncommon occurrences the ideal thing
would be my prescription for that would
be you work with an actual mental health
professional in a clinical setting I
know people will say well Peterson's a
psychologist okay that's fine but people
that are consuming his pop stuff is his
tours and stuff that they're not having
a relationship with a mental health
professional the way I'm thinking of in
terms of psychotherapy you would go and
you would find a good therapist that is
not that that works in a way that you're
comfortable with and you would explore
what you're experiencing in that way you
might read nonfiction about the world
right i think that it's often very a
really great thing and it can be
life-changing to go and get books about
science and the history of the universe
and philosophy and history and geography
right inform yourself about all of the
things that go on in the world and how
the world came to be the way it is in
combination with may be working with a
mental health professional and of course
some people are
feeling that way because they may have
some kind of underlying psychiatric
condition and in those cases you you
know medication may be appropriate there
in some of those cases the next step
that a lot of people would go to would
be pop self-help okay
the reason that Peterson is getting a
bunch of these young men that are going
to him is because they either don't want
to or don't have the resources sometimes
to go the first route which is to spend
time learning about the world and maybe
in a talk therapy situation but they see
the normal pop self-help stuff as kind
of [ __ ] for them right it would it
would be it wouldn't feel right to a lot
of them to go to just like normal
it's the self-help section at your local
bookstore and to pick up some self it
would feel not manly and it would feel
very sis so they want that self-help
perspective but wrapped up in some sort
of machismo and that's what they get
from Jordan Peters and that is exactly
where Peterson comes in you've got these
men who don't feel as though or aren't
in a position to go route number one
that I mentioned they wouldn't really
feel good about themselves if they did
the standard pop self-help stuff so what
Jordan Peterson has packaged up for them
is really unremarkable pretty standard
self-help ideas they've been repackaged
into language that feels better for a
lot of these young men the persona
that's been built around Peterson is of
this truth teller who's not going to
kowtow to political correctness and
using pronouns that he doesn't think are
the right pronouns to use so it's just
like the its marketing its it what it is
is marketing and that's why these
individuals are going towards Jordan
Peterson rather than towards all sorts
of other options that they could go to
and it's at a particularly interesting
time because with the advancement of
modern technology and social media and
we know how people interacting with
these platforms and content can be
affected in ways that aren't
particularly positive
you also have arguably a resurgence of
people who are sort of like in the
market for the type of thing Peterson is
offering so that's what it is and I
I'm open to having my mind changed as
some people like to say you don't think
that Peterson's advice is insightful
like you know I sit up straight now I
have much better posture I clean my room
every day it's changed my life for the
better here's the thing old I don't want
to laugh it off because for a lot of
people hearing that type of thing is
actually useful
there's nothing uniquely insightful or
useful about getting it from Peterson
other than maybe feeling better about
the packaging and the marketing
background you've been repackaged yeah
we've got a great bonus show for you
today I'm out of time because I spent so
much time responding to that voicemail
but the bonus show is great membership
is great patreon is great and I'll talk
to you then